TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Play Billing Library
simplifies the development
process for Google Play
billing, allowing you to focus
your efforts on your app.
And the official 1.0
release is now available.
Head on over to the post
linked in the description
below for a video
introduction and code.
Cloud GPUs can accelerate
your workloads, including
machine learning, training and
inference, geophysical data
processing, simulation,
molecular modeling, and more.
And now, faster
GPUs are available.
And Nvidia P100
GPUs are now in beta
and Nvidia K80 GPUs are now
generally available on Google
Compute Engine.
And sustained-use
discounts are now
available on both the
P100 and the K80 GPUs.
Google Cloud Dataprep is an
intelligent, fully-managed
Cloud service that visually
explores, cleans, and prepares
structured and unstructured
data for analysis or training
machine learning models.
And now, it's available to
everyone as a public beta.
Check out the post
for more details
and a video introduction.
Cloud Natural
Language enables you
to extract critical
information from written data.
And we recently launched
two new features
that can help you further
organize your content
and better understand
how your users feel.
For more details on the
launch and a tutorial
on classifying text,
check out the links below.
Committed Use Discounts are
now generally available.
They are ideal for predictable,
steady-state use of Google
Compute Engine instances.
They require no
up-front pay payments,
and allow you to purchase
a specific number of vCPUs
and a total amount of memory
for up to 57% off normal prices.
More details are on the post.
Stackdriver Debugger
lets you inspect
the state of an application
at any code location
without using log in statements
and without stopping or slowing
down your applications.
And we just announced
that Stackdriver Debugger
for Node.js is now
officially in beta.
The agent is open source
and available on EVM.
Get started with the post.
Our latest research
with Ipsos suggests
that people are three times
more likely to pay attention
to online video ads
versus television ads.
And within the
online video, people
pay nearly twice
as much attention
to video ads on YouTube than
they do on other social media.
Head on over to the post
to review four new tools
to help you capture
the attention
of your audience on YouTube.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, And
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching another
episode of "The Developer
Show".
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
they're right over here.